the indispensable nation is just a happy
mythology we like to tell ourselves
to justify policies that we happen to
already do many times for other reasons
Hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV
today we're talking with Trevor Thrall
he is a senior fellow who covers defense and
security issues at the Cato Institute
he's also a professor at George Mason University
Trevor thanks for talking to us
Nick great to be here
you have written a fair amount about
the Trump Doctrine
obviously this is a bit you
you know it's constantly being
revised it's like a google doc that
probably has 50 different people
you know monkeying with it
how do you see like how can we
meaningfully talk about Donald Trump's
foreign policy and what it's likely to go towards
yeah great question
I think it's he's so inconsistent it is a
little tricky putting your finger right
on it but i think we now know enough
that we can identify at least three big
pillars to start talking about it
the first is embodied in that
America first tag line and that is a sort of
über American nationalism and what I
think that really means at heart is
that Trump is indifferent to really the
the project of the post-world war two
American foreign policy regime which was
building and maintaining a
liberal international order
he doesn't care about the liberal international order
he cares only about America's
NATO other allies
providing global public goods like
safe passage in the ocean he doesn't think
or care much about any of those things
so that's number one
number two is
on the other hand you might think that made him
sort of a dove or something but
I think the second thing is that he's
actually hawkish he's actually very
I don't think he wants to intervene very
often doesn't care too much about the rest of the world
but when he does I think he wants
to bring the hammer and so if you listen
to his words about ISIS
I'm going to bomb the shit out of them
eradicating radical Islam and stuff like that so I think
he's you know he's not interested in the
general project of liberal internationalism
but when it comes to push and shove
I think he kinda has a zero-sum way of
thinking about the world we're gonna win
and we're going to beat people up hard to do it
and I think the third piece that
we've seen very clearly and also kind of
stems from the America first tagline
is his economic nationalism which is
again very a big break from the
Republican party for sure but even from
Democratic elites so you know
trade war with China is on the horizon
that sort of stuff
tariffs and you know
no support really that I can see for free trade